deux ordinateurs avec une configuration
équivalente à gauche le pc est équipé du
système adsl le téléchargement d'une
page web dure 3 secondes
quant aux portables avec son modem
classique il va mettre un peu plus de
temps utilisateur de lignes
téléphoniques classiques les internautes
ont une obsession est une critique
majeure le temps d'acquisition avec ce
nouveau boîtier l'ordinateur et 30 à 50
fois plus rapide est juste deux petits
fils de cuivre est une technologie qui
permet pour la première fois de suivre
un programme de télévision l'ordinateur
n'enregistre plus de simples séquences
vidéo qui demande de longues heures
d'attentes
il diffuse en direct pour ce maître de
conférences accroché 5 à 16 heures du
maçon écran c'est une révolution
la case et vos cases mais l'auteur pour
télécharger présentateur dette explose
et kazim ou télécharger des disquettes
un dossier de recherche de 700 pages en
15 minutes
l'intérêt devient immense pendant des
années les chercheurs ont misé sur la
seule fibre optique pour les
transmissions à haut débit une merveille
très coûteuse oscille france telecom
développe un système souple face à la
concurrence le service offert sur le
câble est beaucoup plus rapide mais la
ressource et partager ses crocs câble
est lui-même partagé entre les multiples
aux utilisateurs un instant donné
notamment chargé le service en abs elle
est un service auquel on garantit une
ressource de connectivité de
transmission à l'abonné et donc il alla
la quasi certitude d'avoir du large
bande ou du haut débit en permanence
tant qu'il est tout à fait normal qu'ils
payent beaucoup plus cher pour ça et le
médian que devient internet dès lors que
le haut débit et garantit presque plus
rien à voir avec ce qu'il veut quand il
est offert sur le réseau téléphonique
commuté
on était en passe du vidéotex à la
télévision le portable a mis une minute
quarante 280 francs par mois
communication limitée l'adsl permet une
chute des prix considérable pour les
passionnés qui s'engouffre dans le web